Ich bin froh, dass es die Schule gibt
sonst wäre mir langweilig.
Einfach zu merken, das ist da das Thema, und
das ist hier das Ziel, und da muss ich noch schauen.
Man hat sehr viele Sachen gleichzeitig
im Kopf.
Ich habe keine Lust.
-Ah, was, keine Lust-!
Das ist mein Charakter. Wenn ich keine
Lust habe, dann mache ich es nicht.
Für mich arbeiten wir hier mit Kindern
und nicht mit Büchern oder mit Lehrmitteln.
Was ist dein Berufswunsch?
Schweinezüchter und Jäger.
(Mona) Ich bin drei Tage in der Gesamtschule
des Bergdorfs Tenna. 1654 Meter über Meer.
Guten Morgen miteinander.
Ihr habt gesehen: Mona ist bei uns.
Sie macht die nächsten drei Tage
Schule mit uns.
Das Ziel ist,
dass sie am Mittwoch unterrichtet.
* Kichern *
Das ist das Ziel?
- Ja, erste bis sechste Klasse.
Jetzt hast du drei Tage Zeit.
- Okay.
Wir schauen dann zusammen.
- Werist nervöser: ihr oder ich?
(Kinder) Du.
- Ich, oder? Das glaubt ihr auch?
Sie wissen, wie es funktioniert.
Sie kennen das.- Ja.
Kommt bitte
mit den Töpfen nach vorne.
Elf Kinder sind hier -
erste bis sechste Klasse,
alle zusammen in einem Schulzimmer.
Du kannst dich dazusetzen.
Wie heisst du?
Ich muss die Namen lernen.
Leandra, Sara, Tabea, Jonathan.
Genau.
- Gut. Jonathan.
Das Thema sind die Formen:
Welche Form ist das?
Mauro?
- Ein Viereck.
Richtig. In der ersten Klasse
ist das ein Viereck.
Und in der fünften
oder sechsten Klasse?
Giacomin?
- Ein Rechteck.- Genau.
Ich habe zwei Säcke vorbereitet.
Ihr ertastet eine Form
und wenn ihr wisst, was es ist,
sagt ihr es euren Kollegen.
Ein Kreis.
Für die erste Klasse
sind die da oben wichtig.
Für die fünfte und sechste Klasse
sollten bitte alle
korrekt benannt werden.
Lea
muss fünf verschiedene Lernprogramme
unter einen Hut bringen -
nur in der zweiten Klasse
hat es kein Kind.
Das ist
ein gleichschenkliges Dreieck.
Oh, jetzt aber. Tatsächlich.
Was macht das aus?
- Dass die Seiten gleich lang sind.
Genau.
Sind hier Kinder,
deren Geschwister auch hier sind?
Seid ihr zwei Geschwister?
Ist er dein kleiner Bruder?- Mhm.
Wir kommen zurück ins Plenum.
Alle Kinder
haben einen neuen Wochenplan.
Die sind hinten aufgehängt.
Eure Aufgabe ist jetzt,
selbstständig zum Plan zu gehen.
Mauro, was machst du,
wenn ihr zum Plan gehen sollt?
Auf dem Plan schauen,
was wir als Erstes machen müssen.
Genau.
Töpfe bitte versorgen.
Jede Klasse
hat einen eigenen Wochenplan.
Jedes Kind
lernt in seinem eigenen Tempo.
Ah, schau mal:
"Sende Lea ein Foto davon."
Duzt ihr eure Lehrerin?
- Ja.
Echt? Das höre ich zum ersten Mal.
Wo ist sie? Ah, da. Normalerweise
sagt man doch "Frau ...".
Wie heisst du?
Hitz. Aber ich finde Lea
viel schöner und angenehmer.
Das macht keinen Unterschied.
Das ist einfach ein Name.
Sie haben deshalb
nicht weniger Respekt.
Jetzt muss ich aber schauen,
damit sie wissen wie, wo, was.
Die Lehrerin wird in Tenna geduzt,
und überhaupt erscheint mir
alles ziemlich familiär.
Aber deswegen nicht weniger streng.
V.a. für Lea.
Was ist die grösste Herausforderung
an diesem Unterrichtsmodell?
Die Koordination. Jetzt haben wir
gerade alle das gleiche Thema,
aber es gibt auch Wochen,
in denen die einen Bruch-
und die anderen Plusrechnen lernen.
Alles unter einen Hut zu bringen
ist schwierig.
Das muss gut geplant werden.
Man hat 10 Min. mit diesem Kind
und dann muss man weiter.
Das Kind
muss das in den 10 Min. aufnehmen,
damit es selber weitermachen kann.
- Ja.
Lernen sie an so einer Schule
selbständiges Arbeiten?- Ja.
Ich denke, das ist
auch wichtig fürs Leben.- Ja.
Alle machen halt was anderes.
Es ist herausfordernd,
fünf Programme im Kopf zu haben.
Für dich.
- Ja.
Man muss wissen, was das Thema
hier ist, welches Ziel man da hat,
dass man dort noch schauen muss ...
Man hat viele Dinge
gleichzeitig im Kopf.
Das ist manchmal anstrengend.
- Das glaube ich.
Mauro will auch was wissen.
Was gibt denn fünf plus zwei?
Mauro ist der Jüngste und
der einzige Erstklässler in Tenna.
Acht, sieben, sechs, fünf.
Ja, prima.
- Da ist auch ...
Fünf, sechs, sieben,
acht, neun, zehn, elf, zwölf,
13, 14 ...
Wieso ist das so?
- Keine Ahnung.
Wenn du dir die Rechnungen ansiehst,
was ändert sich da?
Was?
Fünf bleibt ja immer
und die andere Ziffer?
Was passiert mit der?
Fünf und dann kommt
immer eine höhere Zahl hinzu.
Dann ist das Resultat
auch immer um eines grösser.
Ah ja, das ist eigentlich logisch.
So wäre die Aufgabe
viel leichter gewesen.
Jetzt hast du den Trick.
- Dann wäre das elf.
Das gibt ...
Neben dem Kleinsten
sitzt die Grösste - Leandra.
Du bist jetzt in der sechsten Klasse,
oder? Wo gehst du nachher zur Schule?
In Valendas
in die Sek oder in die Real.
Und ins Gymi? Könntest du das nicht?
- Das wäre mir zu aufwendig.
Darauf habe ich keine Lust.
- Was, "keine Lust"?
Das ist mein Charakter.
Wenn ich keine Lust auf etwas habe,
mache ich es nicht.
Ehrlich? Müsstest du
noch etwas daran arbeiten?
Ja, das sollte ich.
Ich verstehe das sehr gut.
Ich bin da ähnlich.
Weisst du schon,
was du werden willst?
Eine Idee wäre Zeichenlehrerin.
Aber eher für Sek
oder in den höheren Klassen.
In der ersten Klasse kann man
nur Kartoffelstempel oder so machen.
Da fällt mir nur das ein.
Dann müsste ich doch ins Gymnasium.
Oder in die Zeichnungsschule.
Das ist das,
was nicht ganz funktioniert.
Es wird schon irgendwie gehen.
Hoffentlich.- Hoffentlich.
Bist du schon fertig?
Das hast du schön ausgemalt.
Über keine Linie raus. Cool.
* Klatschen *
Das Klatschen
ersetzt die Schulglocke.
Die braucht es hier oben nicht.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Ich erfahre in der Pause,
dass Lea keine Einheimische ist.
Sie lebt in Chur.
Sie ist 29 und seit vier Jahren
hier an der Schule.
Welcher Typ muss man sein,
um als Lehrerin hierherzukommen?
Ich fand es schön,
weil man so individuell
mit den Kindern arbeiten kann.
Ich landete per Zufall
während meines Studiums hier.
Es war eine coole Erfahrung
und dann wurde eine Stelle frei,
weil jemand schwanger wurde
und ich konnte bleiben.
Ich genoss es hier und blieb hängen.
- Ja.
Würdest du ganz hierherziehen?
- Das möchte ich nicht.
Als Lehrerin ist es auch besser,
wenn man nicht dort wohnt,
wo man arbeitet.
Etwas Distanz
ist auch nicht schlecht.
Sie lacht. Bist du
die andere Lehrperson? Ich bin Mona.
Hoi. Ja, ich bin die andere.
Mona, freut mich. Wer bist du?
- Hallo, ich bin Uschi.
Uschi. Lea meinte gerade,
es sei nicht schlecht,
wenn man an einem anderen Ort wohne.
Ich lebe auch nicht an dem Ort,
wo ich arbeite.
Ich wohne dort drüben am Berg.
Dort, woher die Sonne kommt.- Ah.
Hast du immer
in Gesamtschulen unterrichtet?
Ich arbeite seit Langem hier.
Das gefällt mir sehr.
Was macht es aus für dich?
Wir arbeiten mit Kindern,
nicht mit Büchern oder Lehrmitteln.
Die Kinder und ihre Bedürfnisse
stehen im Mittelpunkt.
Und was sehr schön ist:
Man begleitet sie über Jahre.
Anders als in Zürich,
wo meine Kinder zur Schule gehen
und es
über 22, 23 Kinder pro Klasse hat.
Uschi ist zwei Tage pro Woche
als Lehrerin in Tenna.
Nebenbei ist sie Ziegenbäuerin.
Unser neues Thema ist das Wetter.
Das ist ein cooles, altes Thema.
Auch wenn es immer wieder neu ist.
Die Aufgabe der Kinder ist es,
ein Bild auszuwählen,
es ins Heft zu kleben
und zu beschreiben,
was man mit diesem Bild
über das Wetter sagen kann.
Du machst sehr schöne Buchstaben.
Manchmal auch nicht.
- Die sind aber ganz schön.
Manchmal
habe ich keine Lust zu schreiben.
Und dann?
- Schreibe ich extra fein.
Wenn sie "fester" sagt,
drücke ich wie ein Stier.
Dann bricht der Bleistift.
Dann muss ich ihn spitzen
und verschwende so Zeit.
Ah, das ist sehr gut.
Aber dann hast du bald
keinen Bleistift mehr.
Schau, ich habe noch den hier
und auch noch den hier.- Ah ja.
Den ...
- Meine Güte.
Im anderen Etui
habe ich auch noch zwei.
Sag mir,
wenn ich dich unterstützen kann.
Wenn du geduldig bleibst
und sie starten lässt,
zeigt es sich von allein.
- Ja.
Ist das ein Trick - machen lassen?
Machen lassen
ist sehr, sehr wichtig.
Alles was man selber macht,
bleibt dir.
Du darfst gerne ...
- Mal schauen, ob ich helfen kann.
Man muss die vier Richtungen
hinschreiben, stimmt das?- Ja.
Zuerst die Himmelsrichtungen,
dann die Winde.
Hast du ein Lieblingswetter, Elias?
Schnee.
- Warum Schnee?
Ich schaufle gerne Schnee.
- Nein.
Darum mag ich Schnee.
Wir haben eine kleine Schleuder.
Die nutze ich oft.
Die Schleuder ist mir lieber.
- Das dachte ich mir.
Du machst nicht alles von Hand.
Du gehst Schneeschleudern.- Ja.
Ich heue auch sehr gerne.
Diese Maschinen
sind halt schon praktisch.
Ja.
- Oh, du heust gerne?
Du nicht?
* Lachen *
Viele Kinder hier
stammen wie Elias und Jonathan
aus Bauernfamilien. Aber nicht alle.
Madlaina z.B.
zog mit sechs mit der Familie
aus dem Zürcher Unterland hierher.
Sie ist die Einzige in der Klasse,
die ins Gymi will.
Madlaina kann dir selber sagen,
was sie ausprobiert.
Ich habe gehört, dass du
für die Gymiprüfung lernst.- Ja.
Wieso willst du die machen?
Ich weiss nicht,
was ich werden will.
Wenn es Ärztin wäre,
brauche ich das Gymi
und ich würde mich ärgern,
es nicht gemacht zu haben.
Stimmt.
Wenn du in die Kanti in Chur gehst,
siehst du ja die Leute hier
kaum mehr.
Das ist halt so.
Aber ich freue mich
auf grössere Klassen.
Das ist cooler,
weil da auch mehr Kinder sind.
Ja.
- Man hat dann neue Freunde.
Aber es ist schon etwas doof,
wenn man die Leute von dort, wo man
wohnt, nicht mehr so oft sehen kann.
Gut, mach noch ein bisschen
an deinem Kreuz weiter.
Ich versuche es.
* Ruhige Klänge *
So über alles gesehen:
Was denkst du,
nehmen die Kinder
aus einer Gesamtschule v.a. mit?
Verglichen mit Kindern,
die im Unterland in eine
"konventionelle" Schule gehen?
Jeder ist relativ wichtig
und es kommt nicht darauf an,
ob du extrem begabt bist
in diesem oder jenem.
Die Person, die zu unserer Gruppe
gehört, ist wichtig.
Dadurch werden sie selbstbewusst.
Das müssen sie sein, weil sie
ihren Weg selbst meistern müssen.
Es ist Zeit, aufzuräumen.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Die Kinder können nach Hause -
Uschi, Lea und ich noch nicht.
Je schneller du bist,
desto früher haben wir Feierabend.
* Lachen *
Du machst gar keinen Druck.
Die Arbeiten kontrollieren
und Prüfungen korrigieren.
3 Std. Nachbereitung sei normal,
sagt Lea.
Sie lebt richtig für ihre Schule.
Wohnst du da vorne im Hotel?
- Wohnen ist übertrieben.
Ich habe einfach ein Zimmer für zwei
Nächte in der Woche, als Entlastung.
Ich mag nicht jeden Tag
von Chur hoch- und runterfahren.
Das ist lustig, ich treffe Leute
von überall her im Alpenblick.
Da gibt es
die eine oder andere Begegnung.
Das ist mein Zimmerchen.
Klein, aber es reicht.
Ich brauche nicht mehr.- Ja.
Die Aussicht ist super.
Oh ja. So toll.
Wie müde bist du nach so einem Tag?
Man ist abends schon müde.
Man weiss, was man gemacht hat.
* Ruhige Musik *
Kurz nach 7 Uhr morgens sind wir
schon wieder auf dem Schulweg.
Kennst du
alle hier im Dorf persönlich?
Auch die, die keine Kinder haben?
- Ja, fast alle.
Hallo. Das ist Thomas.
- Guten Morgen.- Morgen.
Er ist Jonathans und Tabeas Vater.
- Ah.
Gingst du auch hier zur Schule?
- Ja.
Wie viele wart ihr?
- Hm ...
Als wir am wenigsten waren,
waren wir fünf Kinder.
Erste bis sechste Klasse.
- Oh.
Das war das kantonale Minimum.
Da schwebte das Damoklesschwert
über dem Dorf.
Die Schule hätte zugehen können.
Das hat sich
zum Glück wieder verändert,
aber es ist immer knapp.
Ist es überhaupt cool
mit so wenigen Schulkameraden?
Wäre es nicht klüger,
alle zusammenzunehmen,
damit sie mehr Kollegen haben?
Für den Zusammenhalt im Dorf
ist es toll,
wenn sie hier zur Schule gehen
können und so wenige sind.
Wer hier zur Schule ging, hält
auch wie Pech und Schwefel zusammen.
Merkst du das auch heute noch?
- Ich finde schon.
Man sieht dem Dorf an,
was wir alles geschafft haben.
Das haben wir in den letzten Jahren
nur miteinander geschafft.
Wir wollen diese Schule.
Ja, das hätten wir gerne.
Thomas, du musst auch arbeiten.
Du bist Bauer, oder?
Genau, ich muss in den Stall.
Tschüss.- Tschau, Thomas.
Das Damoklesschwert
hängt immer noch über der Schule.
Jetzt sind es elf Kinder,
aber wenn die Sechstklässler gehen,
sind es nur noch sechs - ab
fünf Kindern droht die Schliessung.
Das Schulhaus ist ab 8 Uhr offen.
Dann trudeln sie ein,
geben ihre Hausaufgaben ab,
spielen oder plaudern.
Dein Papa hat gesagt, er sei
immer gerne zur Schule gegangen.
Ich gehe auch gerne zur Schule.
Ich bin froh, dass es sie gibt,
sonst wäre es langweilig.
Wie ist es,
dass ihr hier so wenige Kinder seid?
Du kannst dir deine Freundinnen
nicht gross aussuchen.
Du musst die nehmen, die es hier hat.
Ist das manchmal mühsam?- Nein.
Ich finde sehr schnell Freundinnen.
In einem Hotel brauchte ich 5 Sek.
und hatte schon eine Freundin.
Sicher?
- Mhm.
Welches ist deine beste Freundin?
Sara.
Und Leandra habe ich auch gerne.
Ja. Yes, Leandra.
* Lachen *
Yeah.
Du bist ja bald ein Teenager.
Ist es cool, so abgelegen zu wohnen?
Ich bin gerne hier.
Hier kann man machen, was man will.
Es ist meiner Mutter egal, wenn ich
erst um 18 Uhr nach Hause komme.
Sie weiss, dass mir
wahrscheinlich nichts passiert.
Kannst du dir vorstellen, mal
wegzuziehen, oder willst du bleiben?
Ich will schon mal weg,
aber dann wieder zurückkommen.
Wenn ich 30 bin oder so.
Morgen, Mauro. Gut aufgestanden?
- Ja.
Mauro, du kannst starten.
- Mhm.
Dritte Klasse:
Arbeite am Wochenplan weiter,
bis der Wecker klingelt.
Wenn er klingelt, machst du hinten
FaceTime mit Safien.
Vierte und fünfte Klasse:
Ihr beginnt mit dem Wochenplan.
Sechste Klasse: Ihr braucht Zirkel.
Dann kommt ihr
an den Gruppentisch nach hinten.
Gutes Arbeiten.
An einer Gesamtschule
lernt man selbstständiges Arbeiten.
Aber die Kinder
lernen auch vieles voneinander.
* Ruhige Musik *
Jonathan rechnete heute via Tablet
mit Julia von der Schule Safien,
ganz hinten im Tal.
Hoi.
Fangen wir einfach mal an?
- Ja.
"Die Form hat vier Ecken,
alle Seiten sind gleich lang."
Ja, Viereck.
- Antwort G geht auch, "Quadrat".
Wieso lernt ihr so miteinander?
- Ich bin allein in der Klasse.
Es ist eine Abwechslung,
wenn man mal mit jemandem zusammen
etwas machen kann.
Ja.
- Mir geht es gleich.
Du bist auch allein in der Klasse.
Ist es besser oder weniger gut,
wenn man allein in der Klasse ist?
Manchmal gut, weil man immer
der Beste und der Schlechteste
in der Klasse ist.
Manchmal schlecht, weil es ohne
Klassenkameraden langweilig ist.
Ja.
"Wenn ihr noch Zeit habt."
Ja, haben wir noch.
* Mona lacht. *
"Rechne aus: sieben mal sechs."
42.
Ja.
16 geteilt durch 8.
- Zwei.
Zwei.
Fertig gerechnet.
(Alle) Tschüss.
Ich bin sehr gut in Mathe.
- Sicher?
Ist es überhaupt wichtig,
wie gut man in der Schule ist?
Will man ins Gymi, ist es schon gut,
wenn man gut in der Schule ist.
Welchen Berufswunsch hast du?
- Schweinezüchter und Jäger.
Schweinezüchter und Jäger?
- Ja.
Aha.
Dein Papa hat Highland-Rinder, oder?
- Ja.
Du willst lieber Schweine züchten?
Wieso?
Ja ...
Weil Schweine
schöne und herzige Tiere sind.- Ja.
Schweinezüchter und Jäger -
das ist doch schon mal ein Plan.
* Ruhige Musik *
Wenn man das so sieht, hat man
das Gefühl, es sei eine heile Welt -
kein ADHS, keine sonstigen Diagnosen,
kein Ritalin,
keine getrennten Familien.
Ich lache,
weil es bei uns genau ...
Klar, es ist ein wunderschönes Bild.
Es ist ein schöner Arbeitsort
und wir haben coole Kinder,
aber bei uns
gibt es auch Lernzielanpassungen.
Wir haben auch Abklärungen
beim Schulpsychologischen Dienst,
wenn jemand
die Lernziele nicht erreicht.
Für einen Elternteil hier
ist es genauso schwierig,
wenn die Lehrerin sagt,
es laufe nicht rund.
Das ist hier genau gleich.
Wir haben die gleichen Strukturen
wie in der Stadt.
Was kannst du den Kindern mitgeben,
was in einer 23er-Klasse
schwieriger wäre?
Sie haben hier
mehr individuelle Förderung.
Das könnte ich
mit 24 Erstklässlern nicht machen.
Sie lernen
mit Gross und Klein umzugehen.
Sie lernen die verschiedenen Rollen:
Zuerst gehören sie zu den Jüngeren
und müssen etwas zurückstecken.
Je älter und grösser sie werden,
desto mehr haben sie zu sagen
und desto mehr können sie bestimmen.
Ich finde das Soziale
in der Klasse schön.
Im Turnen am Nachmittag lerne ich das
heimliche Wahrzeichen Tennas kennen:
den Solarskilift.
Guten Nachmittag miteinander.
Wir machen zuerst zwei Abfahrten:
Menschenslalom
und dann fahren wir zur Bank dort.
Du kannst hinterher.
- Jawohl.
Skifahren ist nicht so meins,
aber ich gebe mein Bestes.
* Ruhige Musik *
Das Skilager
ist das einzige Trauma,
das ich aus der Schule habe.
Ach, du meine Güte!
Das gibt es bei uns nicht so.
- Wo geht ihr hin?
Wir gehen nach Zürich ins Lager.
- Ehrlich?
Du machst eine umgekehrte Welt?
- Genau.
Was zeigst du ihnen?
Dreispurige Strassen?
Mal Tram, Bus und Zug fahren,
dann ins Technorama.
Das kann man von hier aus nicht.
Die Kinder kommen hier oben
wohl schon mit Ski an den Füssen
zur Welt.
Jetzt geht es in den Tiefschnee?
Richtig tief ist er nicht mehr.
- (Kinder) Nein.
Sogar den Heimweg
machen wir auf den Ski.
Uh, meine Güte.
Ich begleite Sara und Elias
nach Hause,
um ihre Mutter,
die Schulrätin von Tenna, zu treffen.
Ja, die Aussicht ist nicht schlecht.
- Aussicht inklusive.
Bist du auch hier aufgewachsen?
- Weiter hinten.
Aber auch in diesem Tal?
- Ja.- Okay.
Genau.
Muss man Angst haben,
dass die Schule zugeht?
Ja, man muss
einen Plan im Hinterkopf haben.
Wenn nichts Besonderes passiert,
sind es ca. fünf Jahre lang
sehr wenige Schüler.
Dann müssen wir was machen.
Dann muss der Schulrat
wohl oder übel tätig werden.
Hast du einen Plan?
- Wir haben ein bisschen einen Plan.
Das sind aber
keine spruchreifen Szenarien:
Das Einfachste wäre, alle Schüler
nach Versam zu schicken.
Aber das ist selbstverständlich
nicht das, was wir gerne hätten.
Dann haben wir hier nichts mehr.
Kinderlachen im Dorf ist viel wert.
Das wäre eine Variante.
Was gibt es noch?
Wenn man sich mit anderen Standorten
zusammenschliesst,
könnte man drei Klassen hier
und drei dort haben.
Das sind so die Ideen.
Aber ich bin optimistisch gestellt,
dass da noch was passiert
und wir
noch ein paar Kinder mehr haben.
Wie wäre es,
herziehenden Familien Geld zu geben?
Andere Gemeinden machen das.
Da sind wir ja
bei einem anderen Thema.
Mit der Wohnsituation
ist es auch nicht einfach.
Wir gründeten
eine Wohnbaugenossenschaft,
um ein Haus übernehmen zu können.
Es hat Wohnungen, Mietwohnungen,
aber relativ wenige.
Wir haben einfach nichts
an leerem Wohnraum.
Ihr habt also auch keine Häuser,
um viele neue Familien anzuziehen?
Nein, zurzeit nicht.
Aber wir sind dran.- Okay.
Statt Ferienwohnungen wieder
Lebensraum für Familien schaffen -
das ist der Plan.
Ich brauche auch noch einen Plan,
denn morgen gilt es ernst.
Ich muss zwei Schullektionen geben.
* Ruhige Musik *
Ich muss mein Zeugs zusammensuchen.
Turnen und Mathe muss ich geben.
Das ist auch so was: Diese Bändel
hat man nur in der Schule.
Eigentlich
eine schreckliche Erinnerung.
Ich brauche sie jetzt trotzdem.
Was brauchen wir sonst noch?
Einen Ball. So einen weichen. Hat es.
Ich wollte tatsächlich in einem
früheren Leben Turnlehrerin werden.
Das ist das Allerbeste.
Aber ich riss mir das Kreuzband
und dann war die Sache erledigt.
Vielleicht
war es so besser für die Kinder.
Ich werde immer nervöser.
Eine Premiere.- Aber du
kannst so gut mit Menschen.
Das ist doch ganz was anderes.
- Findest du?
Ja, stell dir vor.
Es reicht nicht, gut reden zu können.
Du brauchst ein gutes Gefühl dafür,
wie viel man fordern
und zulassen kann,
wie viel man abwarten
und erklären soll ...
Du brauchst brutal Nerven.
- Ja, Geduld.
Das habe ich ohne Ende
mit den Kindern.- Ehrlich?
Mit mir selber
habe ich manchmal keine,
aber mit den Kindern unendlich.
- Eben.
Das ist auch nicht so meins.
* Lachen *
Schau, Jonathan
will ja Schweinezüchter werden.
Er hat die halbe Schweinezucht
aus Pompons hergestellt.
Schau dir das an.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen zusammen.
Hoi.
Ich habe mir alles überlegt,
nur das Wichtigste nicht.
Wann fängt die Stunde an?
Weiss das jemand?
Um viertel nach?
Gut. Also. Guten Morgen.
Am Morgen sprechen wir Hochdeutsch,
habe ich gesehen.
Unser Schultag heute:
in der ersten Stunde Mathematik,
dann Turnen.
Nach der Pause
machen wir Deutsch und Ethik.
Und am Nachmittag habt ihr frei.
Was ist dort,
wo man den Zirkel einsteckt?
Wie heisst das da?
- Der Mittelpunkt.
Der Mittelpunkt, genau.
Während ich in die Geometrie
abtauche, braucht Mauro Hilfe.
Ich habe das schon gemacht.
Dann kannst du es
auf deinem Plan durchstreichen.
Dann siehst du,
dass du es gemacht hast.
Dann kannst du
mit dem Geobrett arbeiten.
Und auch die sechste Klasse steht an.
Seid ihr schon fertig?
- Ja.
Mit Messen, Aufzeichnen und allem?
Super.
Dann könnt ihr
am Wochenplan weiterarbeiten.
Wo ist Mauro?
- Ist er dir abhandengekommen?
Wo ist er? Ah, da!
Er streicht seine Aufgaben durch.
Er macht das perfekt.
Wie es sich gehört.- Super.
Jedes Kind auf seinem
individuellen Weg zu unterstützen
ist so wichtig
und gleichzeitig so schwierig.
Vielleicht setze ich darum im Turnen
auf ein Kontrastprogramm.
Nordpol.
Tamburin-Drill -
ein Gruss aus meiner Schulzeit.
Eis.
Wasser.
Jetzt spielen wir Panterball.
Panterball
ist das Lieblingsspiel der Kinder.
Ich bin die Einzige,
die die Regeln nicht beherrscht.
Oh, darf ich nicht?
Hätte ich nicht laufen dürfen?
Im Eifer des Spiels merke ich nicht,
dass die Stimmung kippt.
Hat es dich voll am Kopf erwischt?
Es gibt Tränen.
Geht es? Alles gut.
Jetzt ist eh Pause.
Aber die Nase ist noch ganz? Gut.
* Lachen *
Es ist gut, wenn du weinst.
So beruhigt es sich.- Danke.
Kümmert ihr euch um sie?
Dann umziehen und in die Pause.
Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, ich
sei kurz vor dem ultimativen Chaos.
Du hast vielleicht Angst,
dass es ausartet.- Ja.
Aber das ist meist nicht so.
Im Turnen
hätte ich etwas früher gebremst,
um am Schluss
etwas Ruhigeres zu machen
und ein bisschen runterzufahren.
Sie wollen unbedingt gewinnen
und steigern sich rein.
Dann passieren diese Unfälle.
- Der Klassiker.
Man will noch schnell.
- Ich eben auch.
Auch? Ja, der Ehrgeiz zeigt sich.
Vielleicht ist es das,
was mich an Lea beeindruckt:
So viel Leidenschaft
für die Kinder und den Beruf,
und gleichzeitig die Ruhe
und Übersicht, die es braucht.
Was wäre dein Wunsch an
die Gesellschaft und Eltern,
wie man auf Lehrpersonen
oder auch die Schule zugehen soll?
Ich würde mir wünschen,
dass man die Schule
etwas positiver sehen würde.
Mehr als Ort,
von dem man etwas mitnehmen kann,
wo man eine gute Zeit haben
und Freunde finden kann.
Das wäre schön.
Was würdet ihr ändern?
- Die Ferien etwas länger machen.
Was, die Sommerferien?
- Das dürfen wir fast nicht sagen.
Die kommen aus Zürich und haben
nur fünf Wochen Sommerferien,
wir hatten acht.
- Acht Wochen?
Dasist ja
schrecklich für die Eltern.
Heuferien. Da muss man heuen helfen.
- Jeden Tag heuen.
Ja, schrecklich.
- Ich nicht.
Wir haben länger Ferien,
damit wir länger helfen können.
Stimmt. Aber helft ihr auch wirklich?
- Sie schon.
Lieber mehr Ferien -
in dem Punkt sind sich die Kinder
in der ganzen Schweiz wohl einig.
Vielen Dank. Es war megacool.
- Ja, gern geschehen.
Gehen wir nach Hause? Du und ich?
- Nein, ich komme nicht mit.
Ist gut. Tschau.
Drei Tage an der Gesamtschule Tenna.
Gerne würde ich in 30 Jahren
noch mal kommen, um zu schauen,
ob dann auch noch Kinder
in Tenna zur Schule gehen -
wie Jonathan, Leandra oder Elias.
Die Gesamtschule von Tenna, das sind wir
uns bewusst, ist ein spezielles Beispiel dafür,
wie Schule aussehen kann. Ich bin gespannt darauf,
wie Eure Erfahrungen mit Schule aussehen.
Es gibt ja sehr viel Kritik an Lehrpersonen
aber auch am Schulsystem.
Findet Ihr, unsere Kinder lernen wirklich das,
was wichtig ist im Leben,
oder läuft unser Schulsystem in eine
falsche Richtung?
Eure Kommentare bitte gerne unten
in die Kommentarspalte.